and helping a child in need find a
stable home Mary Jane beliesza shares
one local man's story he called into our
community phone bank one night to raise
awareness on adoption and the available
resources throughout Clark County
Larry Bowen says it wasn't in his plan
to adopt a child so late in life but
says it was the best decision he's made
you know it's changed my whole life
Larry and his wife retired in 2007
fostering many children in Clark County
over the years and then during that
process we adopted little boy two days
old he's now 11 which he's a wonderful
boy his mother lost parental rights as
soon as he was born he says it takes
more than a Father's Love to raise a
child but to provide a safe and loving
home that's why he's raising Awareness
on adoption in Clark County and the
available resources for families they
need homes and it's sad that a lot of
these kids just don't get placed because
the public doesn't know about it Jessica
Rowe is the vice president of programs
for raise the future connecting children
in foster care with stable homes we all
support reunification from the minute
that that child enters foster care
and at times it's not deemed safe or
appropriate for that child to return
home to their family and that's where we
really come in and focus on those youth
who need a permanent family Rose says
raise the future has helped placing
close to 11 000 children in pre-adoptive
homes and supporting families with the
help they need it's low cost so um there
there's a minimal cost associated with
um you know background checks and
fingerprinting and all of the training
um that people can go through all of
that is free all of our services are
free to families as well Bowen says he
was required to Foster Samuel for one
year before the adoption process if I
was about 20 years younger I would have
probably adopted more of these children
called it that's where my my heart is
because I've been there I went to three
different foster homes as a child
in order to be an eligible adoptive
resource you need to be a licensed as a
foster parent first for Clark County's
Department of Family Services and accept
foster care placements within 30 days of
being licensed